bindi Irwin enjoys a romantic sunset
with her boyfriend and I have my family
my mum and brother here with me and then
to have Chandler here as well and I
think that that love and support is just
it's something that we all we all need
in life we need those people to keep us
going that was 17 year old bindi Irwin
gushing 2et about her beau wakeboard Pro
Chandler Powell back in September the
couple is currently in bindis native
Australia and on Saturday they showed
off some adorable PDA on Instagram the
pair enjoyed some quality time together
outdoors at the Australia Zoo bindi
shared this cuddly pic and wrote in the
caption watching the sunset with lemurs
jumping in the trees overhead what a
perfect way to end the day hashtag
blessed Chandler returned the affection
posting this smiley shot writing sunsets
lemurs Islands and an amazing girlfriend
what more could I ask for
sounds like bindis ideal date she
recently told et will always be
Australia and honestly I can't wait to
get back to all of my animals
I meant to just go and lay under the
trees with my snake and my Rhinos it'll
be so nice